[Music]
the sessions called life of a service
event really the intent here is to just
a little bit lift the cover on what goes
on underneath in the service
infrastructure that we have in cloud
what the building blocks that we've
built on to provide the the service
products that you can use so before we
get started I just wanted to level set
on an assumption here and the assumption
is that we all agree in principle that
service generally is the place that we
want to be you're not managing
infrastructure you're not dealing with
load spikes we'll deal with that for you
you're not spending time managing things
that don't add value to your business
you've elevated yourself to a to a
higher plane of existence however there
are some problems definitionally we gave
you a black box and we said you don't
have to worry about all this magic we'll
do it for you but that leads to some
issues in terms of visibility and
transparency you might see some latency
and increase and how do you reason about
what that might be maybe your build
times suddenly got longer why is that
and then you might see different
behavior in one environment versus
another or you're hitting some weed
quota limit and how do you reason about
it so the theory is great you don't have
to worry about it anything the reality
is you still have to worry about these
things so the purpose of this session is
to just give you an insight into what's
going on underneath there so that you
can reason about these with with more
intelligence and obviously you would
have logging and monitoring and all
sorts of things in place but as
engineers I think it's useful to know
what are the mechanics going on under
here so we'll cover these four topics
first of all what's the definition of
service compute on cloud platform
secondly what happens when you deploy
what steps do we actually take when you
when you write that command line
g-cloud functions deploy what happens
when Reis we receive an event or a
request how does that travel through the
system and what happens and then we'll
close with some best practices what do
you do with this information once we've
revealed it to you so let's compute on
cloud platform covers two products
mainly cloud functions an app engine
I'll be referring to these throughout
the talk as as an app and a function you
deploy an app with App Engine you deploy
a function with cloud functions and
there's just a distinction that I've
made there an app is something that
reacts to requests a function is
something that reacts to events you know
there's many distinctions you can make
that's that's just illustrative okay how
do we build a service compute platform
now if you wanted to go and build your
own server list compute platform I'm
going to tell you how to do it now so
take notes and if you want to go out and
start building your own then this is how
you do it step one you need a global
footprint of data centers it's pretty
simple there are actually servers
underneath service as you would know
google has a global distribution of
machines in data centers so it all
starts there the next layer that we have
is something that we've talked publicly
about it's this thing called Borg and
what it is is a shared compute
infrastructure that runs pretty much
every service in Google everything from
Google Maps to YouTube to search and and
also cloud and it's premise is that
Google engineers in fact operate service
Lee and have done for a very very long
time
they don't reason about physical
infrastructure they just create tasks in
Borg and those tasks go and execute the
caveat is that it only runs trusted code
it runs code that is cryptic
cryptographically verifiable as goo
code and your code I hate to say it is
untrusted so how do we run untrusted
code earlier in the year at Q con we
talked about the open sourcing of a
project we called G visor and G visor is
a unique technology that we've created
that is a sandboxing technology it
allows us to isolate processes on a
shared computer infrastructure from a
security standpoint so process a has no
mechanism by which it can interfere with
process B this allows us to run
untrusted code on an otherwise trusted
infrastructure so above the data center
above Bourg above these secured
processes we have a serving routing and
scheduling layer the serving is the data
plane that receives requests it's
responsible for routing it does things
like if a zone in a data center is
unavailable it will automatically move
an application to a zone that is
available for that sort of failover
guarantee and the scheduling part of it
is the thing that decides whether a new
instance of your application needs to be
created whether there's an old instance
that can be evicted and and makes those
decisions to to auto scale you up and
down and above all of that is a Google
front-end the Google front-end sit at
the edge they sit in front of every
single Google service once the request
hits the Google front end from that
moment onwards it's on the Google
Network so on the Google operator
network from the Google front end and it
does some has some other characteristics
like it does SSL termination it does
some amount of denial service protection
and that's the main entry point at the
edge okay so does all of these layers
does it all work if we send this many
requests per year one hundred and seven
two hundred and twenty seven trillion
that's a meaningless number but really
it's about four million QPS on this
infrastructure this service
infrastructure across both cloud
functions and herp engine
that's a pretty big number okay let's
get to the good stuff I'm gonna talk
about the lifecycle what happens when
you deploy when you execute that CLI
command what's actually happening and
then once your application is serving
traffic how do we route the request to
you and what's going on how are we
scaling up and down and what are some of
the side effects of of the
implementation we have okay first of all
deployment you in to enter this command
into your CLI or you use the UI and the
first thing that happens is build we're
going to build your concretely in the
case of App Engine and cloud functions
we're going to build a container image
and the latency there is going to be a
function primarily of the file size and
in network speed to get the data up to
us then we're going to actually crunch
that together into an image and most of
the time spent there is resolving
dependencies particularly in cloud
functions we have this ability to
resolve the dependencies for you if
there's any no js' developers in the
audience who recognize this as a package
like JSON file that you will upload
along with your source code that
declares a set of dependencies in python
and requirements txt we will go and
resolve those for you and bake it into
an image so you don't need to upload all
of your dependencies in one going once
it's built we create or update that
instance on the infrastructure and the
latency there is a function of two
things one is cold starts which I'm
going to talk a lot about today and the
other is a rolling deploy which doesn't
seem like a latency impacting thing but
the idea here is that you already have a
version of your application running you
want to make a change to it that version
is already serving traffic you don't
want to kill that traffic you want to
gradually roll that out so the time
between when you made the change when
you updated the function and it becoming
available across the fleet is not
instant it's never atomic and so there's
an amount of time that that's going to
take that could be perceived as sort of
deploy time just reiterating
at the point we build this dependency
resolution we have some caching
mechanisms there if you depend on a
particular version of a particular
module or library and and we can
reliably identify that you've seen that
before
we'll pull it from cache and then the
rollin deploy again it's not atomic it
happens over the course of time
depending on how much traffic you have
you have a lot of traffic and there's a
lot of instances of you of the old
version then it will take longer for the
rollout to complete if dependencies
change a side effect of the caching
obviously if if dependencies change then
the build time might take longer because
they're not cached ok what happens when
we serve so we have the from the diagram
before serving and scheduling these red
boxes represent the instances of your
application a request comes in if we
don't have a instance that is available
to serve a request then we'll create a
new one we'll scale up and this implies
a cold start I might be preaching to the
converted here in the sense of what a
cold start is but it it warrants some
some some detail ok I'm gonna take a
quick detour I put this slide in to
remind me that it's a detour and we'll
talk about three things really quickly
this is a little bit complicated but
I'll do my best
concurrency and billing products like
cloud functions one of the advantages of
this is you're not paying when you're
not using it and even more fine-grain
than that you're only paying while your
code is executing now you can imagine
that let's say I have a function and
I've said I I would like 512 megabytes
of RAM please and my function executes
for 10 seconds and so I'm paying for 10
seconds of wall clock time multiplied by
the amount of memory and the amount of
CPU that I've been granted for that
period of time if I was to put another
request at the same time in there the
billing gets
a little bit complicated am I being
charged for both requests at 512
megabyte am i sharing it somehow what if
they're not at the same time one starts
now one starts halfway through it starts
to get very very complicated the
simplicity of the billing model means
that we're constrained to a single
request for instance so a function is
billed per request independent of the
instance it's not your problem whether
there's a thousand instances or one
instance to serve that request we might
be doing a really poor job of our
scheduling and have a thousand instances
sitting around costing us money but it's
not costing you anything an app
conversely you pay for the lifecycle of
the instance independent of the request
this is a fundamental difference in the
model and the reason I have the slide
here is just to make this clear an app
will deal with many concurrent requests
because it doesn't affect the billing at
all the only thing that affects the
billing is the life cycle of that
instance and that instance will stay
alive as long as it's serving requests
so this has an implication to things
like cold start this chart along the
bottom I have the frequency of cold
starts how often do they occur and on
the y-axis upwards I have the duration
how long does each cold start take these
two heavy phases are places that we
would be okay with one where a cold stop
happens a lot but it doesn't take very
long and the other where it might take a
long time to start but it doesn't happen
very frequently a virtual machine is
very much on the top left and we hope a
cloud function is very much on the
bottom right it is necessarily
definitionally going to have more cold
starts because it deals with a single
concurrent requests and we're scaling up
and down we don't want a lot of machines
sitting around costing us money that
means we have to charge you more so
we're going to try to be reactive very
quickly to these spikes and troughs in
traffic but it means that you want the
cold start time to be low
typically this manifests in a difference
between the primitive an app or
typically cold-start less frequently and
you can imagine this scenario an app
let's say it takes ten concurrent
requests before its resources are
exhausted within another instance of it
if you only have ten requests between
QPS let's say you don't need one
instance so that you're starting very
infrequently you definitely don't want
to be this person very frequent cold
starts that take a long time that's the
worst place to be this would be the
awesome place to be but it's a bit
mythical very very infrequent cold
starts that don't take very much time at
all
I mean it does happen you might have a
function that has a very quick cold
start that's called once a day and
that's great but if you're building a
large application the likelihood of this
happening is pretty low but as long as
you're in one of those green spots
you're probably okay okay so this makes
the distinction the the choice you're
making between the primitive pretty
important if you're building something
that is multi-purpose so it has many
endpoints like imagine a restful api
that has many endpoints maybe there's
some shared state maybe you have a
connection pool or some bit of memory
that you're sharing between requests and
you want to deal with many concurrent
requests at once because of this shared
state then you would err on the side of
an app if however your compute unit is
single purpose it really just has one
job there's no shared state all the
state is stored outside and you're okay
with a single request at a time
and by the way single request at a time
is often much simpler you have to deal
with far fewer race conditions when you
only have a single request in scope any
one moment then a function is where you
would tend to tend to find yourself okay
there's the end of my detour okay
again on this idea of app versus
function in the app case and this chart
represents CPU time so you know M cycles
or clock cycles and then along the
x-axis the the wall time the time back
in the real world imagine you have two
requests sequentially one request starts
and finishes second request starts and
finishes and some amount of time in
between the blue line here represents
CPU usage effectively so in an app let's
say the first request uses a little bit
of CPU the second request uses what uses
a lot and there's this time in the
middle where the CPU is being used this
is important because as I said before
the billing model says I'm paying for
the life cycle of an instance so I
should be able to do anything I like
during that life cycle and this is true
in the case of CPU usage if I'm only
paying while my request is in scope as
in the function case then there's not
going to be any CPU activity in between
those requests because there's no
billing model that accommodates for it
so request number one the billing starts
on the left and then when that request
ends we stop charging you if we allowed
your CPU usage in that gap free bitcoins
for everyone so this will become
important further on ok so an app model
builds for the life cycle of an instance
it handles concurrent requests and
accommodates for compute time outside of
the scope of a request a function builds
for a lifetime of a request handles a
single concurrent request and assumes
this sort of freeze-thaw model in
between requests where no CPU activity
is going to be allowed to happen
ok eviction so we talked about request
comes in we don't have an instance
available so we're going to create an
instance for you and then you have a
trough in your traffic and we have a
thousand instances lying around what
policy do we use to evict these
instances to remove them from our
infrastructure
okay that's just showing one in division
is so generally instance eviction is
lazy meaning that we will tend towards
evicting instances when we need the
infrastructure that they are consuming
but not before the reason for that is
that the machines on the data center
floor largely have a fixed cost whether
your process is running there or not
there's an opportunity cost to us if
that you have a process that's running
and we need that space for somebody else
and you're not using that space in which
case we'll kick you out generally though
what we try to optimize for is not
whether we are creating or destroying
instances that's much much more of an
implementation detail we just try to
optimize for performance we monitor
things like latency we monitor things
like cold starts because they're bad for
performance and we try to optimize the
scheduling algorithms too or try to
alter the scheduling algorithms to
optimize for those two things as a side
effect of the concurrency that I
described before apps will tend to have
cold starts less frequently and that's
because when each subsequent request
comes in it can be dealt with on the
same instance and the the time between
well the number of instances we have to
create to serve the same QPS is fewer
and then the last point is sometimes
instances just go bad maybe you hit an
out of memory error and even though that
request that caused the out of memory
error is long gone the machine has found
itself in all the instances found itself
in a bad state will detect that and will
cease to send traffic to them because
we're ceasing to send traffic to them
they will become viable for eviction at
some later point okay quick recap
service is awesome it's also not awesome
when you can't know what's going on
Google knows how to service you all due
to now so I expect to see many service
compute competitors emerging after this
presentation and then we talked about
the lifecycle what happens at deployment
we talked about atomicity of deployment
instance creation destruction cold
starts apps versus functions background
theories we didn't talk about
specifically but this was the compute
time in between the requests okay but
what do I do with all this amazing
information that I've just been told
okay there's some sort of patterns and
ante patterns that I want to talk about
so let's look at some common some common
pitfalls that people fall into number
one are we choosing the right primitive
are we trying to jam an entire java
spring application into a function and
is that the right thing to do how do we
how do we what can we do to improve our
cold start time what are the what are
the best practices there oops I'm sorry
what do we do with background threads I
have this thread that's running in the
background a common pattern in in web
applications is received at a request
respond quickly and do some work in the
background well that's not going to work
in a function because once you've sent
the request the response back that's a
signal to us that you're done and we're
gonna throw a little CPU down and your
background task may or may not complete
what do you do with this auto-scaling
where we scale out beautifully and you
don't know how of service your own
database because it can't deal with the
traffic that we've been sending it
because we auto scale and I'll talk a
little bit about idempotency towards the
end okay not number one choose the right
primitive do you want to put your big
Java monolith into a cloud function
probably not you can you're going to
have a horrendous cold start times and
then I haven't very frequently and and
everyone has a bad time do I put my big
Java monolith in to App Engine maybe why
wouldn't I well I wouldn't if I'm
relying a lot on state service compute
products work best when they assume that
they're stateless if you have to persist
state you might find you will find
circumstances where the requests where
you assume that state was there finds
that it's not there now it's a great
performance optimization that you might
be cashing things and if it's there it
works faster and it's not you can go get
it and that's fine but this is why I say
maybe the best thing to do is to make
sure that the application has the
appropriate granularity of services very
very tiny services cloud functions and
medium sized services app engine some
anti-patterns with relation to cold
starts again if you assume a stateful
environment then this might be
problematic what I mean by that is that
you know in a classic monolithic web app
it's very common for the start to load a
bunch of state maybe it's loading things
from a database into cache
maybe it's instantiated objects ahead of
time and Stanzione in Singleton's
whatever the case may be this design
pattern assumes essentially the virtual
machine style of mode of operating where
you start up the VM it does a bunch of
work it might take five minutes to stop
that's okay because you're only doing it
like once a month this doesn't translate
well to service because this start/stop
cadence is much more frequent and then
the last point there is this primitive
choice choose the right primitive now we
knit we Google need to do the right job
in making that easy for you but really
choosing the right primitive set you off
on the right foot from the beginning
okay here's some code in case you didn't
notice if there's any nodejs developers
in the audience don't come and attack me
afterwards because what I'm going to
show you is pretty much the antithesis
of what a node.js developer will tell
you is best practice and they'd be right
but I'm going to show it to you anyway
because I think it's a good illustration
this would be pretty common
in in a node application and I'll just
unpack what's happening here I have some
libraries some dependencies they are
being required at the top of my file the
first thing that happens and then I have
two functions declared in the same
JavaScript file do something and do
something else
each function uses only one of those
dependencies and I said this would be a
totally sane pattern in an application
model or on a virtual machine the first
function uses the first dependency the
second function uses the second
dependency everyone's happy the problem
is the second function doesn't use the
first dependency so if I was deploying
these as separate cloud functions even
though they are in the same source file
the do something else would be its own
function but at cold start time it would
be loading the first library even though
it never ever uses it now multiply this
by 10 how do you know that all of the
things that you're doing at the start
and I'm not I'm doing something pretty
innocent here all I'm doing is following
node best-practice I'm just requiring
much I'm not loading a case I'm not
doing anything silly I follow what they
told me but the side effect of this is
that each function when deployed
individually is bearing the cost of all
the other functions so this is unwanted
cold start time it doesn't offer me
anything it just cost me money it's more
insidious example the function is using
both libraries but only conditionally so
if my query string foo only equals bar
in one out of a million requests then
all the other requests are paying the
price for that in terms of cold start
time this takes a little bit of
relearning in how we do things we have
to be mindful of what's going to happen
at startup when I deploy this thing we
often hear oh such-and-such product or
such-and-such platform has has good or
bad cold start times but largely it's
dependent on this code that we write
okay this is where I'm gonna get in big
trouble I'm not saying necessarily do
this but this would help I only require
the library when it's actually required
now really great feature of note is that
that require statement will be cashed
and so the subsequent invocation of that
on the same on a hot instance it's
effectively a no op but this is again
just illustrative the else condition
that happens in most cases let's say
doesn't pay the cost of the some huge
Lib that's loaded in the if condition I
hope that makes sense okay I want to
invite my colleague Monica on stage
she's going to give you a demo can we
switch to demo please so my name is moon
Canaveral I'm software engineer in cloud
functions team and for the purpose of
this talk I created the demo that
illustrates what Jason has just said so
it operates on cold start and life cycle
of cloud function so in my demo I
created the functions or rather every
functions that two more do more or less
the same thing but in a slightly
different way so I integrated functions
with slack so slack is cloud-based tool
that aids team collaboration so I have a
my slack channel and I also created a
free custom commands that are hood with
functions so integrations is very easy
as you can see there's a command and
there's URL that should be called
whenever this command is called and it
points to a function so let's try our
first function
[Music]
so dysfunction well all of this function
do the same thing as I said before so it
they expect a term in the slack channel
and then they put this term in the
knowledge graph API and threat reef
information about this term from
knowledge graph and then returns a
response which contains the data from
the knowledge graph so you can learn
something about this particular thing
from knowledge graph API so the first
function is written in application like
style so as you can see first we extract
the text so the term that was written in
this doctrinal then we use a local cache
so first we try to retrieve information
from the cache and if it's not there
then we are making the actual query the
query is done here so we just put the
query to the knowledge graph API and we
extract the first math the first result
and then we do the formatting so we are
converting the message returned from the
API to the format that can be displayed
on a snack Channel so because it's
application like style function I also
do some pre loading so let's say that my
slack channel is about traveling and
people often look for information on the
countries so I want to make this
experience for them really good he'll be
fast so I'm pre loading some data
associated with countries so in another
file I have the list of all countries so
now let me go to my slack channel and
try this try to call the first function
and what actually happened is that slack
has quite aggressive timeline that
timeout for the responses and from the
web hooks hood for the comments and
because we are doing this pre loading we
experience the situation when actually
the function was executed correctly but
just like didn't wait for the result
however like any further
for the crawl for the API should be
extremely extremely quick so now let me
go to the lots of dysfunction just to
see what exactly was worth the number so
how much did he take for a function to
execute so as you can see the first name
equation took more than three seconds
just because we were holding all the
terms however any consecutive request
was processes very quickly because we
could serve the response directly from
the cache so now let's go to the second
function which would be written in a way
that it's completely stateless so this
is kind of thing that you can expect
when writing code functions so again I'm
extracting text from the request then
I'm not using a local cache as before
I'm just directly calling knowledge
graph API each time I am calling this
function I have also this dysfunction
that form as the query I am done and I
do not do any pre loading so now let's
go back to the channel and try the
second function so as you can see I'm
receiving the results recently quickly
[Music]
so drawn you can see it works so let's
again look up the exact numbers how long
this function was executed each time so
as you can see like each time it takes a
few hundred milliseconds to finish
however the user experience is
definitely better but still that times
are not not perfect so really the the
best approach would be the one presented
in the first function
and so you can go to the source
so again extracting the query but we
also use a local cache and so we are
trying to retrieve the result from local
cache if it's there if it's not we are
acquiring a knowledge graph API however
we don't use any pre loading so we
optimize for concept but we still think
that it it might be it makes sense to
use a cache on best of all basis so
let's see how it works so for different
terms its
it works similar to the previous
function however for the terms that I'm
executing for the second time the
function executes much quicker because
they could be served from the cache so
let me see the logs so as you can see
there is still a cold start that is that
takes longer than consecutive indication
because this new instance needed to be
created however the any consecutive
request for the same term can be very
quick
so to summarize like this demo shows two
things the first that you should really
optimize for a cold start because they
happen they happen any time traffic
pattern changes a new function instance
need to be created and like as you can
see in this example this cold start cold
start time if it's too long may mean
that your function is unavailable for
the user and the second thing that
platform is smart enough
so we not disposed your function
instance just after it was executed
because it can anticipate that there
will be some traffic so it still makes
sense to use a local cache to optimize
the results so this all that I prepared
so we can switch back to the
presentation thanks Monica
yeah so what we just saw there was a
much better version of what I put on
screen actually done by real engineer
okay
so just to summarize it's important to
understand and optimize for cold starts
they happen when a new instance is
created we will create new instances
when they're needed and then because
functions only servicing will current
request because billing it happens even
more frequently in the functions case
again this period of time in between
requests in the function case and what
do you do with that with with background
threads or background tasks that you
might be running as I said it's very
common in the sort of web application
world that you might want to early
respond to a request and then do some
work some more heavy lifting in the
background this is not going to work
very well in a function abstraction
because of this CPU throttling behavior
the best practice here is if possible
wait for all the work to complete before
you return if you want to give the user
or the caller a response early then you
should you it's we would recommend that
you use some sort of event bus like a
pub sub n queue a message on that event
bus have some other function somewhere
else that's going to do that background
processing and then return and it's not
just because of this CPU throttling
behavior that we would say this you can
imagine the request comes in I spawn a
thread I'm going to do some heavy
lifting over here but I'm responding
immediately and then I get halfway
through the heavy lifting and this
anything crashes for whatever reason out
of memory process dies what happened to
that work what are the guarantees that
I'm providing myself over that work
probably much better is to have an at
least once guarantee on an event bus
like pub/sub so that if it does fail it
will retry and eventually succeed
can i special call-out to connection
pools somewhat unsolved problem
traditional database my sequel Postgres
take your pick will have a finite number
of connections that can deal with on a
particular instance or in aggregate you
have a spike in traffic and overwhelms
the database too many connections and
this is displayed here in my nice
graphic there's a couple of things you
can do here there isn't really a silver
bullet for this because it's a
fundamental mismatch there's a
fundamental sort of impedance mismatch
between a finitely scaled resource and I
I hesitate to say infinitely but much
larger scaled compute layer above that a
couple of things you can do data access
service pattern and scaling controls I
think I repeat myself there so limit
exposure to the database to only the
services that need it don't just throw
your connection pool into every single
function you do be diligent and
judicious about who is accessing
accessing the database one other idea is
to break your database up itself now
sometimes difficult if you're relying on
foreign keys and things like that but as
a pattern it can be useful limit
connection pools the connection pool
size and we have this sort of somewhat
strange recommendation that we make in
cloud functions where you create a
connection pool to a database like my
sequel and you limit it to a size of one
why do I need a pool if it's a pool of
one why don't I just make a connection
well
it's limited to one because first of all
you're only dealing with a single
concurrent request so the likelihood
would be ever needing more than one is
pretty low and secondly if you just left
it default and let's say the connection
pool framework you're using says I'm
going to create ten connections by
default every single instance of that
function is going to create ten database
connections you're going to run out of
connections pretty quickly the reason we
say to use a connection pool is really
just a convenience because many
connection pool frameworks will do
things like reestablish the connection
if
found to be bad and so you just get
greater reliability by leveraging that
kind of retry behavior that's that's
native to the connection pool another
thing you can do is use rate limits at
an API level or scaling limits at the
infrastructure level for those who saw
the presentation yesterday we talked
about a new feature in functions that's
coming soon which allows you to limit
the amount that we scale up so you can
have some levers there to say please
don't ddos my database I can only deal
with a hundred or a hundred connections
I know I have one connection for
instance I know I have a hundred
instances maximum or use a quote unquote
serverless database like cloud datastore
where we handle that scaling for you
okay last point idempotency I have a
quote there yeah which is sort of often
attributed to Einstein I'm not sure if
he actually said it doing the same thing
over and over again expecting different
results
was he talking about idempotency I'm not
sure
so idempotency is when I perform some
operation and no matter how many times I
perform that operation the outcome
doesn't change it changes the first time
and then doesn't change thereafter so
this is really important because in many
circumstances particularly in
asynchronous event-based functions the
guarantees are at least once at least
once means will execute you at least
once but not exactly once and there are
circumstances where you will will you be
executing more than once and you know I
have a reference to something like an
upset there where you can mutate the
data but if you do it again nothing
changes
a concrete example this is actually my
inbox from about two or three weeks ago
I don't know if this was an item potency
thing but it seems like it might have
been I received and actually it was more
than 19 I took the screenshot to
prematurely but you can imagine this
situation where you have a bit of code
and it's sending an email but it's
sending in the email and then it's doing
something else and there's something
else fails and they have a retry policy
and so it's sending the email in failing
and then sending email in failing so it
is not idempotent so a failure that
leads to a retry is correct behavior you
want this thing to happen but a failure
that does causes mutations or sends SMS
messages or whatever it might be and
then fails is definitionally not
idempotent so there's many ways to solve
for this we're not going to dig deep on
that now just something to be mindful of
particularly in service particularly in
asynchronous where at least once
guarantees other norm
[Music]